[Applaudissements]
pour le candidat giscardestin la qualité
essentielle reste le sang
frroid il présente son équipe son
calendrier ses
objectif et je ne voterai pas
ajoute-t-il pour François
mitteran mesdames messieurs bonsoir la
France comporte depuis 24 he de nouveau
champion du monde teran recordman du
monde de durée de candidature à la
présidence c'est Valérie jiscardestin
qui l'a dit hier soir et puis Valérie
jiscardestin lui-même champion du monde
des promesses non tenues c'est François
mitteran qui vient de le dire cet
après-midi la campagne est donc lancée à
un mois et demi du premier tour et bien
lancé on s'est traité de tartuf de Basil
et de matamor en quelques heures rafale
l'intervention des principaux candidats
Jacques Chirac à carthur table lundi
soir Valérie juscardestin au grand débat
hier soir George Marchet devant
l'Association de la presse présidenti C
à l'heure du déjeuner et enfin donc
François mitteran cet après-midi dans
une conférence de presse reprenons donc
les derniers éléments à commencer par
cette prestation du candidat Giscard
desestin hier soir ses échecs ou son
échec en tout cas pour lui le chômage
c'estes sujets de satisfaction
l'amélioration de la condition des
personnes âgées la politique énergétique
la paix s'il perd au premier tour s'il
se retrouve derrière Jacques Chirac ou
Michel Debray il appellera les Français
à voter pour eux au second tour s'il
gagne ce sera ser alors son dernier
mandat et sa préoccupation prioritaire
sera de régler le problème de l'emploi
et de parler la jeunesse voilà
rapidement résumer les thèmes principaux
de cette intervention dont on retiendra
aussi la réaction très vive aux
accusations personnelles type affairire
des
diamants l'idée c'était en terme de Tour
de France l'équipe française Tour de
France c'était de méqueurer salider de
faire en sorte
que on se sente atteint ou qu'on est
plus la foi ou l'ardeur de vouloir
continuer le combat politique en raison
de la bassesse des attaques c'était ça
l'idée c'était de M queurer et ben
c'était mal me connaître parce que
lorsque au contraire j'ai vu ces
attaques à qui on avait affaire je me
suis dit que je ne laisserai pas la
France être gouverné ou subir
l'influence de gens qui portent les
cornes noires du chapeau de Basil
c'est-à-dire qu' font de la calomnie un
instrument de du débat politique pour ma
part jamais été désespéré jamais été
écœuré à aucun moment j'ai étéis blessé
oui j'ai été écœuré non
j'ajoute que valériardestin effectuera
six déplacements en province entre le
premier et le second tour on ne sait pas
encore dans quelle ville François
mitéran qui sera à son tour l'invité de
carte sur table lundi prochain a voulu
répondre d cet après-midi au propos du
président sortant Jacques Merlino a
assister à sa conférence de
presse
c'est une conférence de presse en demi
tenu cet après-midi François mit à deux
reprise il précisa qu'il ne répondrait
pas complètement à toutes les questions
ajoutant qu'il réservait certaines
déclarations directement au français
l'essentiel pour François mit était donc
cet après-midi de présenter les équipes
entouré et de préciser à grand trait les
thèmes de sa campagne ces thèmes vont
s'organiser autour de deux axes
l'économie d'abord avec bien sûr
l'emploi et l'inflation et les libertés
avec ouverture d'un débat sur la vie
démocratique si en évoquant ces deux
thèmes François quelquefis à Monsieur
jacquirac ce fut surtout au président
sortant qu'il réserva ses critiques les
plus vives l'impression que j'en ai
retiré comme cela hier
soir c'est que le candidat sortant c'est
un bon candidat
et ce qu' le caractérise le plus
clairement c'est que il est difficile
d'être à la fois aussi bon candidat et
aussi mauvais
Président je ne jugerai pas ces qualités
personnell pas plus qu'il n'a voulu et
je le remercie et apprécier les miennes
eu je ne lui contesterai aucune des
qualités qu'il se reconnaît à
lui-même mais passant de la subjectivité
à
l'objectivité je dirais
que le chef de l'État d'hier candidat
aujourd'hui a une spécialité lorsqu'il
se présente devant l'opinion publique
c'est d'avoir du
cœur beaucoup de cœur 2 mois tous les 7
ans reportage qui a mis du temps à
démarrer mais qui a démarré 2h
auparavant c'était George marchetis qui
était l'invité de l'Association de la
presse présidence tout comme François
mitteran et les grands candidats entre
guillemets il est suivi en permanence
par deux équipes d'Antenne 2 c'est
Jean-Michel merkererol qui suivait la
réunion
d'aujourd'hui c'est un chge marchais
serein sû de lui qui s'est prêté
aujourd'hui au feu roulant des questions
des journalistes ainsi de son séjour en
Allemagne je suis inattaacable j'ai la
conscience tranquille sur la question
des immigrés nous ne sommes pas racistes
nous ne voulons pas les expulser sur les
exclusions intellectuels ceux qui
appellent à voter contre moi doivent
être exclus et puis George Marchet a
défendu l'idée s'il est élu d'un
gouvernement comprenant des ministres
socialistes et communistes mais il s'est
refusé à dire s'il favoriserait au
second tour la victoire de François
mitteron si je suis candidat c'est pour
gagner a dit avec conviction George
Marchet ajoutant qu'il lui serait
désagréable de se retrouver aujourd'hui
au côté de Monsieur giscardestin pour
appeler à voter François mitteran mais
les ATT de George Marchet se sont tout
de même concentré sur le candidat Valéri
giscardestin dont il a dénoncé le bilan
social et économique pour le candidat
communiste le chômage est délibérément
voulu et organisé par le
gouvernement il est vrai qu'avec un air
de fausse contrition monsieur Giscard
destin cherche une excuse au chômage
dans la sampiternelle rangain du pétrole
mais il a un tabou le tabou des profits
là-dessus pas un mot motus bouche cousu
pour les comptes en Suisse les
exportations de capitaux les lingots et
les magot les spéculations les châteaux
et les palaces ce n'est pas
maamort ses
tartufes cacher ses profits que je ne
saurais
VO réaction du côté du RPR Claude Labé
président de ce groupe à l'assemblée
s'est déclaré frappé par la différence
entre Jacques Chirac un candidat qui
propose et engage l'avenir a-t-il dit et
Valérie jiscardestin qui justifie avec
difficulté un lourd bilan Jacques Chirac
précisément juste avant son départ pour
la Guadeloupe et les Antilles et la
guillane a visité aujourd'hui le salon
l'agriculture le maintien des revenus
des agriculteurs et des éleveurs est une
impérieuse nécessité
si l'on veut sauvegarder l'agriculture
française jacquesac s'est bien sûr
arrêté en priorité au stand régional de
l'agriculture d'Auvergne et du Limousin
réaction enfin du PSU le président de la
République a un véritable talent
d'illusionniste Alamel on va essayer
d'aller un petit peu plus loin ce soir
on a vu les quatre prestations des
candidats la campagne est vraiment parti
on peut les comparer aujourd'hui d'abord
on peut juger leur aspect formel le
style les faire chercheron alors d'abord
ce qui est visible c'est que cette
campagne est en train de se dérouler
avant tout au rythme de la télévision de
la radio je dire que c'est une campagne
qui est largement audiovisuelle c'était
déjà vrai en 65 en 69 en 74 je crois que
c l' allait encore plus cette fois-ci
alors de ce fait cette semaine je dis
bien cette semaine il me semble que les
deux candidats qui ont été le plus mis
en avance parce qu'il participaient à
des émissions c'était Jacques Chirac et
Valé GIS cardestin George marché
répondra bientôt dans d'autres émissions
et François mitéran dès lundi à carte
surtable alors en ce qui concerne la
technique des deux candidats principaux
de cette semaine je le dis bien
c'est-à-dire Valérie jiscardestin et
Jacques Chirac qu'est-ce qu'on a pu voir
il me semble que sur un plan technique
Jacques Chirac a cherché à se montrer
lundi je dirais moins tranchant et moins
polémique qu'il ne l'était à d'autres
périodes qu'il a sûrement travaillé
cette technique de télévision qui a fait
il me semble une bonne prestation il
reste peut-être un petit peu polémique
encore pour une élection présidentielle
mais c'était du bon travail en ce qui
concerne Valérie Giscard desestin mais
je dirais que ce qu'on voyait très bien
c'était la la métamorphose du personnage
du président en candidat que apparemment
d'abord il s'amuse plus dans ce second
personnage qu'ensuite c'était quelque
chose qui était plus humain et plus
proche que quand il s'adresse en tant
que chef de l'État naturellement il me
semble que c'était aussi une bonne
performance il a montré qu'il avait
envie de dire pas mal de choses il l'a
dit assez carrément y compris sur des
sujets qui lui étaient désagréables
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure et
de ce fait je crois qu'on a vu
franchement depuis le début de la
semaine deux bonnes prestations alors
au-delà de l'aspect technique et
l'aspect tactique la tactique de de
giscar face à Chirac bon alors ça
c'était tout à fait vis
au fond il tendait un piège à chacun des
deux je dirais qu'à François mitteran il
tendait un piège en lui disantah voilà
si par hypothèse François mitteran éta
élu il a déjà dit qu'il dissoudrait
l'assemblée donc il y aurait une
dissolution de l'Assemblée alors ça
naturellement c'est ça implique l'idée
d'instabilité et puis l'assemblée
dissoute il y aura de nouvelles
élections législatives elle se ferait au
scrutin majoritaire puisque c'est le
scrutin français ce scrutin majoritaire
implique des alliances donc selon
valardestin une alliance entre Franois
et le Parti communiste et comme le Parti
communiste demande des ministres
communistes il y aurait donc des
ministres communistes si la gauche
l'emportait bon ça naturellement c'est
pour arrivver à l'idée selon laquelle il
y a des ministres communistes si
François Méran l'importe alors pour
Chirac il le met un peu au pied du mur
il lui dit si avant nous je le met il le
met tout à fait vous vous rappelez que
lundi soir à carte sur table avec
jean-el cavach on avait demandé à
Jacques Chirac ce qu'il ferait s'il
n'était pas qualifié pour le second tour
et il nous avait répondu malgré notre
insistance d'ailleurs il nous avait
répondu écoutez demandz d'abord aux
autres et puis je vous le dirai à ce
moment-là Val lui a choisi la technique
exactement opposée qui consistait à dire
tout de suite ce qu'il voulait faire
alors dans son esprit naturellement il
sera au second tour mais si par
hypothèse il n'y était pas il a dit
carrément que c'était très simple s'il y
avait Georg Marchet François mitteran il
voterait pour François mitteran et que
si c'était François miterran et Jacques
Chirac ou François miterran Michel
Debray et ben il voterait pour Jacques
Chirac ou Michel Debray il est clair que
maintenant ça contraint Jacques Chirac à
lui répondre et alors si Jacques Chirac
se refusait à lui répondre il aurait
l'air moins net et que s' lui répond il
a l'air forcément d'accepter davantage
l'hypothèse de la prééminence de Valérie
jcardestin bon bah c'est c'est de la
bonne tactique disant que c'est une
nouvelle intervention qui qui change un
petit peu les stratégies des uns et des
autres oui en conseil des ministres ce
matin avait été adopté le projet de
décret qui convoque les électeurs pour
l'élection du Président le 26 avril et
dans ce même conseil le chef de l'État
s'était félicité de la mise en
application de la loi d'orientation
agricole qui a fait l'objet ce jour même
de 13 décrets publiés au Journal
officiel
au centre de cette campagne électorale
parmi les sujets prioritaires l'emploi
l'emploi avec parfois ses aspects
dramatiques ainsi le suicide d'une
chôumeuse d'une entreprise textile dans
les vauges hierer à Val d'Ajol C Vallé
des vauges qui traversent depuis
quelques années de très grav difficultés
le textile on le sait se porte mal
demain par exemple le comité
d'entreprise du groupe agage Villot à
vrechi va avoir à se prononcer sur le
plan de restructuration de l'entreprise
un plan qui passe par des licenciements
il y a quelques 15 000 personnes dans ce
groupe alors pourquoi toutes ces
difficultés pour mieux comprendre Alain
dubeski s'est rendu sur place avec une
équipe d'Antenne 2 et il a remonté la
filière
historique l'est de la France c'est 52 %
de la production cotonière nationale sur
les 314 usines d'il y a 20 ans près de
160 sont déserté aujourd'hui pourquoi y
a-t-il une telle concentration de cette
industrie dans les vuges et bien après
la guerre de 1870 les Alsaciens fuyant
les Allemands trou ouvert ici une
population rurale stable courageuse et
de l'eau beaucoup d'eau pour faire
tourner les métiers et blanchir les
tissus suite alors une longue période
d'intense activité après la Grande
Guerre Marcel bousstac s'installe ici
petit à petit il crée il rachète des
filatures vous voyez actuellement ce qui
fut le berceau de l'Empire bousac cette
ancienne abaye de Cénon dans la vallée
du rabudo Marcel Boussac fait construire
les logements qu'il loue à ses ouvriers
crèche écooles hôpitaux maison de
retraite c'est Boussac il rachète tous
les terrains ayant valeur stratégique
lui et les autres les plus petits vivent
bien pendant plus de 50 années puis
c'est la perte des colonies les
difficultés commencent début des années
70 déclin de Boussac la politique
sociale du vieillard plus des erreurs de
gestion dira-t-on précipite la chute de
son
empire 1978 les frères Villot rachètent
l'ensemble ils suppriment 1200 emplois
départ volontaire et
pretrait 1980 tout craque de nouveau les
importations de plus en plus massives de
textile rendent la vie impossible à tous
les producteurs aujourd'hui 60 % de la
consommation française de tissus coton
vient de l'étranger contre 38 % en
1974 les accords internationaux de
compteagentement type accord multifibre
ne sont pas respectés des dérogations
sont accordées avec la Chine par exemple
et puis il y a les trafics les
tricheries couvertes par les
gouvernement de certains pays citons
l'Italie les USA qui exportent en masse
leur velours vers la ce mais qui dans le
sens inverse barricade leurs frontières
avec des droits de douane allant de 23 à
36 %. chez nous il ne sont que de 15 %.
je pense que les mesures à prendre sont
tout d'abord un contrôle extrêmement
sévère aux frontières parce que si on
veut maintenir une industrie textile en
Europe en France bien sûr et en Europe
il faut que nous puissions disposer une
partie s du marché
européen l'industrie cotonière compta en
1960 118000 salariés en 1979 52000 en
1980 18000 les entreprises disparaissent
une à une 7 dépôts de bilan en 7 mois
chacun dans les V se tourne vers le
groupe le plus important agach V Boussac
safère chacun pense qu'il devra
licencier mais quand et combien si le
gouvernement ne prend pas de décision
rapidement au niveau des importations ce
sont des unités entières que nous serons
obligés d'arrêter 50 % des usines les
nouvelles dispositions concernant le
chômage à temps partiel vous pouvez vous
en servir les exploiter on peut les
exploiter mais dès qu'une unité ne
travaille pas à 40h les prix revient
sont tellement mauvais que c'est nous
enfoncer encore un peu plus donc
impossibilité pour l'industrie textile
de ralentir sa productivité pour être
rentable ce qui peut tourner doit
tourner à plein régime le reste doit
mourir 50 des unités d'après la
direction de bac safère mais elle ne
peut pas prendre seu la décision l'aval
du ministère du Travail est
indispensable pour l'instant un
compromis semble se dégager 1000 emplois
seraient supprimés par la mise en
préretraite du personnel âgé de plus de
56 ans mais cela n'a rien d'officiel
encore autre secteur délicat en ce
moment l'automobile la direction de
Renault véhicule industriel les camions
a bien présenté aujourd'hui comme prévu
au comité central d'entreprise de Lyon
un plan des effectifs par le biais des
départs en préretraite anticipé il y en
aurait 3600 en 3 ans et l'INC confirme
bien ce développement du chômage dans un
bilan qu'il vient de publier sur 5 ans
il confirme cette forcée forte poussée
du chômage une insertion professionnelle
de plus en plus difficile pour les
jeunes un coup d'arrêt à l'immigration
un développement de l'emploi précaire et
puis en matière de durée du travail une
tendance à l'uniformisation vers les 40h
les policiers mécontents aujourd'hui
certains d'entre eux préférait avoir à
mettre moins de contravention et à
s'occuper davantage de la sécurité
l'épidémie de fièvre hateuse dont je
vous parlais hier en Bretagne les
mesures draconiennes d'isolement du
secteur semblent pour l'instant efficac
c'est un véritable cordon sanitaire qui
a été dressé dans les Côtes du Nord
autour d'un périmètre de 15 km sur 5 on
a dû abattre plusieurs milliers
d'animaux et hors du périmètre on en a
piqué plusieurs centaines de milliers un
5è cas de pièvre afteuse a été découvert
aujourd'hui dans cette région des nanal
Près de
l'ambal demain une soirée spéciale de
l'information sur Antenne 2 et europin
une édition à 20h30 consacrée au
problème de la sécurité des maires
communistes socialistes RPR et
giscardien dialogueront avec Christian
Bonnet et Alain perfit des reportages
viendront nouvrir ce débat dernier de
ces reportages a passé en prélude celui
qu'on réalisait dans la région
parisienne François cornet et Pascal
stelletta c'est peut-être le plus
impressionnant ils ont passé 24 heur
avec les effectifs de police secours du
département de la SA sa l'un des
départements les plus touchés par la
délinquence et la criminalité et au
hasard de leur enquête ils ont
pratiquement filmé un meurtre les images
ne sont pas trop violentes nous les
avons volirement expurgé mais elles font
allez voir
réfléchir secours
j'écoute la police nequ pas oui je vous
écoute aubervillier 12h15 il a été
attaqué au couteau dans un
bar police secours je vous
[Musique]
écoute bobini 14h accident de la
circulation intervention des hommes du
17 de police
secours police secours j'écoute
allô adresse ptin 16h cet homme est
neutralisé s'apprêtait à tuer un membre
de sa famille à coup de
hache il sagit qui
men serv pourloger appartement
[Musique]
ilétaitfermz uneire agressé par deux
individus le blanc Ménil 20h40 un homme
de 18 ans vient d'être frappé à coup de
barre de fer dans la rue assassinat
règlement de compte dans une banlieue
oubliée à quelques kilomètres de Paris
il va mourir nous accompagnons les
hommes du 17 de s sa depuis la fin de la
matinée ce meurtre sera l'affaire la
plus importante de la journée vol
trafique de stupéfiant attaque à main
armée agression fut aussi partie du lot
quotidien de police secours
département de s superficie 23500 hectar
1400000 habitants 4000 fonctionnaires de
police dont le personnel administratif
et les agents féminins de surveillance
de voie publique en clair 3500 policiers
sur l'ensemble du département à fort
pourcentage de délinquence et de
criminalité pour assurer la sécurité des
personnes et des biens un effectif
employé selon le principe des 38 avec
son roulement de repos deacances me pour
raison maladie soit un millier d'hommes
présents le jour et la moitié de cet
effectif la
nuit la nuit en permanence nous avons
entre 500 et 600 policiers sur
l'ensemble du département pour assurer
la sécurité d'100000 personnes oui
est-ce que vous trouvez que ce chiffre
est suffisant moi je dis que les la
plupart des affaires qui se produisent
la nu
sont élucid par conséquent cela
soulligne la l'efficacité de nos
services de surveillance de nuit dans le
domaine de l'intervention les équipages
de police secours avec lesquels nous
avons patrouillé sont intervenus dans
tous les cas moins de 10 minutes après
l'appel au 17 la prévention l'autre
volet de la sécurité est une autre
affaire les policiers de cette saintten
ou d'ailleurs font ce qu'ils peuvent
pour enrayer cette criminalité mais la
nuit par exemple un effectif d'un
policier pour 2400 personnes peut-il
couvrir efficacement l'ensemble des
missions la sécurité est un problème de
moyen de formation donc de spécialistes
c'est aussi et avant tout un problème de
choix budgétaire
oui c'est tout à fait le genre de
question auquel nous répondrons demain
donc dans édition spéciale une émission
de Louis berot et des rédactions d' 2 et
d'EUR 1 à 20h30 à l'étranger l'essentiel
des regards est porté sur Damas les
auteurs du détournement de l'avion de la
Pakistan l ont repoussé une première
fois l'ultimatum initialement fixé à
midi tout à l'heure l'ambassadeur de
Pakistan en Syrie et deux parents d'un
pirates sont arrivés à Damas Serge
Misr sur l'aéroport de Damas les 103
passagers du Boeing 720 des liges
internationales pakistanais vivent
aujourd'hui leur 10e journée de
détention malgré la chaleur accablante
les otages doivent respirer un peu plus
librement maintenant depuis le report de
l'ultimatum des pirates de l'air qui
menaçait de faire sauter la pareil entre
les pirates ils sont trois et les
autorités pakistanaises la négociation a
repris et l'on s'achemine vers une
solution l'exigence des ravisseurs de
faire libérer des prisonniers politiques
détenus au Pakistan va être satisfaite
les autorités de Karachi préparent
actuellement la libération et le départ
d'au moins une trentaine de détenus
actuellement incarcérés dans diverses
prisons le responsable du commando que
vous avez vu apparaître au hublot de
l'appareil serait un étudiant en
physique d'une vingtaine d'années
partisan de l'ancien président alib buto
qui a été pendu le frère le père et le
frère d'alamgir c'est le nom du chef des
pirates serait arrivé à Damas pour
tenter de le convaincre de libérer les
passagers et l'équipage de
l'appareil Pologne rien à filtrer pour
l'instant de la rencontre entre le
falessa et le Premier ministre l'
falessa qui confirme son arrivée en
France le 22 mars il restera une semaine
à l'invitation de la CFDT George C Guy
pour la CGT lui avait écrit il y a 15
jours pour lui demander de repousser ce
voyage afin qu'il n'y ait pas
d'exploitation politique de la présence
de Monsieur wallensa en France donc
apparemment lesfessa n'en a rien fait
Londres violente critique contre le
budget présenté par Madame Sacher au
Parlement l'opposition travaill se
déchaîne bien sûr mais aussi plusieurs
personnalités de la majorité
conservatrice et du patronat les
syndicats pas plus que la bourse
n'apprécient bref madame Sacher est bien
seule ce soir Jean-M sauf à devenir du
jour au lendemain à peuple Auster qui ne
fumerait pas ne boirait pas et ne
conduirait pas d'automobile il sera bien
difficile au Britannique d'échapper au
rigueur du 3e budget de Madame Thatcher
un exemple ce paquet de cigarettes il
coûtait 8 francs il coûtera désormais 9
franc50 la bière les vins les spiritueux
et l'essence augmente de 10 à 15 % la
vignette au tau de 17 %. et si l'on ne
relève pas les impôts sur le revenu
c'est l'inflation qui bien sûr s'en
chargera un budget catastrophe qui nous
fera franchir en un an le cap des 3
millions de chômeurs ton les syndicats
un holdup de 3 milliards et demi de
livres affirme le Daily Mail qui tout en
reconnaissant le courage et l'entêement
du chancelier de l'Échiquier le montre
sous les traits d'un raquetteur
présentant sa liste noire mais si la
presse conservatrice rend parfois
hommage à l'entêement du chancelier
comme le dé télégraphe ce nouveau tour
de visce ne fait guerre l'unanimité ni
au sein du gouvernement ni dans les
milieux d'affaires par exemple où l'on
ne cache pas sa déception bien sûr une
baisse honorable du coût du crédit est
la bienvenue mais le gouvernement n'a
pas fait de cadeau au patron ni en
matière de charge sociale ni vraiment en
matière de coût énergétique et ce ne
sont pas les quelques mied jeté au
handicapés ou les avantages modestes
accordés aux petites entreprises qui
empêcheront une chute jugée partout
excessive de la consommation c'est vrai
en réussissant à faire passer
l'inflation en moins d'un an de 22 à 13
% Margaret Thatcher seule promesse tenu
a commencé à tordre le coup à
l'inflation encore faudra-t-il éviter
disent les Britanniques que demain le
malade n'étouffe Iran le président
banissadre menace de démissionner si la
justice ne condamne pas les responsables
des incidents de l'Université de Tan
Jérusalem le parlement israélien
repousse un projet de loi d'annexion du
plateau du Golan Santiago du Chili enfin
le général Pinochet a juré tout à
l'heure de respecter la nouvelle
Constitution élaborée par la jeinte
militaire à la tête Duqu de laquelle il
se trouve une constitution qu' qualifie
d'antiarxiste le général Pinochet rile
pour 8 ans tout à l'heure le Parlement
européen de Strasbourg a observé une
minute de silence à la mémoire des
victimes du régime chilien le
déraillement d'un train ce matin à
villeeneuf Saint-Georges près de Paris
on a eu peur ce soir deux personnes
seulement sont encore hospitalisées
Gérard de cette am et de ces banquettes
déché les sauvteurs retireront 17
voyageurs blessés ce soir deux personnes
sérieusement touché aux jambes sont
encore hospitalisé il était 6h30 ce
matin quand le conducteur de la rame
commence à peine à procéder au freinage
pour rentrer
en